[Musique]
mon père a toujours dit que vous ne pouviez
jamais faire confiance à une personne qui avait besoin de
quelque chose de vous au bureau dont
vous n'avez jamais rencontré quelqu'un qui n'avait pas besoin de
quelque chose de 21 tout en faisant l'
histoire ici, nous construisons un monde entièrement nouveau à
partir de  à la base, je regrette de
signaler que la prison a été violée, nous
devons déplacer la plupart de ce que vous venez d'entendre
avec un mensonge, les ragas se sont libérés, c'est un
carnage dans la ville, je sais que vous avez une
petite fille seule au Capitole si je
ne  ne descendez pas, elle mourra
et s'en sortira par vous-même pas avec ces
choses là-bas
[Musique]
J'ai accès à la sécurité militaire plus proche
vous aider à trouver ma fille
Je vais vous donner refuge ici tout ce que
nous aimons faire pour voyager en toute sécurité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Thomas est Danny
toi
[Musique]